un nuevo reconocimiento ante la
jurisdicción especial para la paz
militares de colombia ejecutaron a
civiles inocentes de forma extrajudicial
son los conocidos como falsos positivos
no eran guerrilleros
sólo eran hombres
o jóvenes que apenas iban a comenzar sus
proyectos de vida donde sólo estamos
asesinando a personas inocentes que no
tenían nada que ver con el conflicto
armado este último reconocimiento hace
referencia a hechos de la primera década
de 2000 en el batallón la popa de
valledupar en el caribe colombiano para
este auto la jurisdicción especial para
la paz imputó a dos coroneles y trece
militares por 127 asesinatos y
desapariciones forzadas sin embargo los
dos altos mandos responsables no
aceptaron los cargos y no estuvieron
presentes en la primera de las dos
audiencias las autoridades indígenas de
los pueblos wiwa y kankuamo denunciaron
que el número sería incluso mayor porque
los encargados de velar de promocionar y
cuidar y respetar los derechos humanos
hicieron lo contrario el ejército
colombiano presentó sistemáticamente en
todo el país a civiles como guerrilleros
fue en el marco de la seguridad
democrática impulsada por el gobierno
del expresidente álvaro uribe con el
objetivo de acabar con la guerra los
militares actuaban bajo presión para
presentar buenos números a cambio
recibían recompensas económicas y viajes
la jurisdicción especial para la paz
surgió en 2016 fruto del acuerdo entre
el estado y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc si los reconocimientos son
considerados suficientes por el tribunal
y las víctimas los acusados podrían
obtener penas restaurativas que no
conlleven prisión